TIN-YUN HO: My name is Tin-Yun
and I'm a Product Manager
on the Cloud AI team.
And today I'm here to talk about
a new product we are launching
for delivering highly
personalized shopping
experiences on GCP.
But before we begin , I wanted
to step back and provide
a little bit of context.
What is so hard about delivering
good recommendations, which
is the key component
of personalization?
Well, if you think
about the basic setup,
it involves, for a given user
in a context that they're
interacting with
UN, recommending
an item from a long
list of potential items
that you can show them.
And there are challenges along
each of these major steps.
So for users, you
have cold start users
that you've never seen before.
You have users who
have shifting habits.
So even if you have
seen them before,
they may not be behaving
the same way anymore.
And you also have the
sparse feedback problem.
They don't actually
interact with every one
of your products.
They only ever
interact with a few.
And frequently only
the head items.
Then you have changing context.
They're on different
pages of your website.
They're interacting with you
from a different device, iOS,
or Android, or what not.
There's changing channel.
Sometimes they're in store.
Sometime there's on
mobile versus desktop.
And then there's
changing location.
They might be signing in
from different geographies.
And finally, items.
You might have a
new product launch,
so it's a cold start
item with no history.
So you don't necessarily
know how to recommend it.
You have sparse labels.
So especially for
the tail items,
you might not have
significant signal on how
people click and purchase it.
And it's hard to recommend.
And then, especially
in the retail setting,
for a lot of your products,
the most important information
is not necessarily in
the clicks and purchases,
but in the
unstructured metadata.
So for example, the
description of a book
or the image of a dress.
And in this situation, with
all these different challenges,
you have to solve all of them to
deliver a good recommendation,
which is actually really
difficult. And by the way,
you have to do this
in 100 milliseconds
with up to billions of items
and billions of users, at least
in the Google setting.
So luckily here at
Google, we've been
able to accumulate
years of experience
across multiple
flagship properties
on how to make
recommendations better,
including with the latest
deep learning approaches.
So for example, in Search, we do
personalized search re-ranking.
With YouTube, we predict what
video you should watch next
based on your viewing history.
In Google Play, we predict what
app you're likely to install,
and so forth.
So here's an example
from YouTube.
Now this was published
in the Verge.
So more than 70% of the time
people spend watching videos
on the site is now
driven by YouTube's
algorithmic recommendations.
That's a significant share.
So in light of this,
both the challenges
as well as the great
recommendations technology
and infrastructure we've
built up at Google,
we decided to
provide all of this
as a managed service to enable
retailers to deliver state
of the art, highly
personalized product
recommendations to their
shoppers in real time
and at scale.
We call this Product
Recommendations
AI, which I'm proud to
announce is in limited beta,
as of yesterday.
The way it works is we provide
a fully managed global scale
service that basically
works out of the box.
And by managed
service, I mean there's
a whole slew of problems
that we solve on your behalf
so there's no need for
you to think about it.
So for example,
there's no need for you
to think about cleaning
and pre-processing
your adjusted data
because we'll do
things like deduplicate
your user events, filter bot
traffic, et cetera,
on your behalf.
No need to think about
writing state of the art
machine learning code,
keeping up with the latest
deep learning advances, making
sure that your models cover
your entire product catalog,
and do so in low latency.
All these are very
challenging problems
and we take care of that
for you, essentially
cherry picking the best of
what is coming out internally
from the other consumer-facing
teams at Google.
There's no need for you
to think about maintaining
resilient training pipelines.
Making sure that your
pipelines run day
in and day out without failure.
No need to think about
addressing common biases that
can skew your recommender, such
as popular items, seasonality,
on sale items, as
well as making sure
that your recommender properly
recommends when it hits
cold start items or tail items.
No need to think
about replicating
your service across regions.
We do that for you.
So wherever your shoppers
are, we can serve it.
No need to think about
provisioning servers
to handle spiky traffic.
Retailers in the
room probably know
that you can have 3x or
even 10x spikes in terms
of user traffic.
So no need to think about it.
We'll automate dealing
with that for you.
No need to think about building
monitoring, error checking,
and learning systems, as
well as relevant dashboards.
So obviously, this is
extremely important in case
your recommendation fails for
some reason in the pipeline.
We'll warn you and
we'll also enable
you to check it and debug
it in your dashboard.
And then finally,
no need for you
to manage the latency,
availability, and cost for all
of these above components.
The way to think about
it is that not only are
each of these steps extremely
difficult to deal with,
but there are also
potential points of failure
for your overall system.
So we take care of all of
that, make it resilient,
make it work, make
it best practice,
and all you need to do is ingest
your product catalog and user
events.
And then from the Predict
API, retrieve and then display
the recommendation results.
And then you only have to pay
for the recommendations served.
So all the underlying
infrastructure costs,
we take care for
you, we bundle it in.
In terms of
recommendation options,
we provide a
comprehensive portfolio
of choices suited for the retail
setting, which you can retrieve
with just a simple Predict API
call, as I mentioned earlier.
So first, you can choose
your recommendation type.
And we have the
primary types that are
needed for a retail website.
For example,
recommended for you,
which is based on your
shopping history, what are you
likely to click on or buy next?
Usually used on the home page.
Other items you may
like for recommending
other relevant items on
the product detail page,
but doing so in a
personalized way,
based on your shopping history.
Frequently bought together.
So suggesting complimentary
items to a current one
that you're already
thinking of buying, as
opposed to a substitute item.
And then shopping cart
and registry expansion.
So let's say you already have
five items in your cart, what
other items go with that cart?
Next, for each of these
recommendation placements,
you can define your objective.
So whether you want to
optimize for engagement
or click through rate
at the time, conversion
rate, or revenue procession.
So we could re-rank the options
based on the price for you.
And finally, fine
tuning results.
So you can do things
like filtering out
of stock items, filtering
duplicate items,
especially useful if you
have a large category
with many overlapping items.
Filter by custom tags
that you provide.
Turn diversification
on or off, as well as
turn personalization on or off.
Usually personalization
will achieve better metrics,
but there might be unique
circumstances where
you don't want to personalize.
And as I mentioned earlier,
as input to the recommender
system, we take your
product catalog, as well as
a live stream of
your user events.
And because we're using
the latest deep learning
architectures, we put
all of your data to work.
Every last ounce of it.
So for example, in
the product catalog,
we not only use the history
of clicks and purchases
for each of those
products, but we also
use the rich metadata that's
available in the catalog you
provide.
The name of the product, the
description, the categories,
et cetera.
All of these things
are used directly
as inputs in the
neural net model
to enable our models to
recommend better, especially
for cold start
items or tail items,
where the only signal
we have potentially
is from the metadata itself.
Next, we also take a live
feed of real time user events
and we use every bit of it.
Not only just the aggregate
clicks and purchases, but also
the exact sequence
of user events,
down to what happened in the
last second in order to inform
the recommender.
So the exact sequence,
the event type
of each of the elements
in the sequence,
the ordering, the distance
between each of the events.
All of these are used as
signal into our model.
As well as things like
the domain and device,
other custom features you might
provide for the event context.
Ingesting this data
is easy as well.
So we have built in integrations
to enable easy data ingestion
from a large number
of touch points
that you already
have with Google.
For example, if you already
send your product catalog
to the Google Shopping team for
managing your product listing
ads, then you can use
the same integration
for Recommendations AI.
Similarly, if you already
use Google Tag Manager
for ingesting user
events from your website,
then we do have a native tag
integration with Google Tag
Manager that you can turn on.
And off course, if
your historic data
is stored in Google Cloud
Storage or BigQuery,
we can ingest from there as
well in order to, for example,
warm start the recommender.
But of course, if you prefer
more traditional options
like a back end API or
a JavaScript snippet,
we have those options
available, also.
And of course, none
of this would matter
if we couldn't deliver results.
And I'm proud to say that, after
working with a number of pilot
customers all over the world,
delivering recommendations
on their full 100% production
e-commerce traffic,
we've been able to
prove our ability
to deliver significant lift
on key business metrics
that you care about, as shown
in AB experiments controlled
by our customers versus
their baseline solutions.
So for example, up
to a 90% improvement
in recommendation-driven
click through rate.
Up to a 50% improvement in
recommendation-driven revenue.
As well as up to a 5%
improvement in total revenue
procession.
I'm especially proud
of this last metric.
It looks small, but actually
it's the biggest one.
Because typically, for
the pilot customers
we worked with,
the baseline tends
to provide only a small
share of their total revenue.
Something like 10%.
We've even seen less than 5%.
So if you can increase the
total revenue by up to 5%,
that's actually a pretty
significant improvement.
And as a caveat,
these metrics are
meant to give you a sense
of the upper ranges of what
we've been able to achieve.
The upper ranges.
The full range of actual
results can vary dramatically
based on a lot of factors,
such as the positioning
of the recommender
on your website.
If you put it at the
very bottom of the page,
obviously we're not going
to impact total revenue that
much no matter what.
The number of products
in the catalog.
The more products you
have, the more likely
a recommender has room to
do innovative new things
that it couldn't do before.
But whether there are any
data integration issues.
And this is actually
the biggest issue
that we've come across when
it comes to model quality.
If people can't
achieve the results,
typically there is some
kind of data integration
issue involved.
Things like maybe
the user events
are not being sent properly.
Maybe the product catalog is
not being updated regularly.
Maybe the predictions
are not actually
being shown in the
appropriate order.
All of these are things that
we've hit on a regular basis
the middle of AB experiments.
So this is probably
the biggest category
of things to watch out for.
And finally, of course, if
you have a large data science
team that has already been
working on recommendations
for many years, likely
you won't see these kinds
of results across the board.
But I believe that
it would be great
if you could test it
on individual locations
that maybe you haven't
worked as hard on.
And then it could still provide
significant lift for those.
So you can think about ways
to mix and match whatever
is the best of breed from
in-house, as well as from us.
That's one of the
reasons why we decided
to price per prediction, so
you can do that kind of thing.
And now I'd like to show
you a demo of our dashboard
from which you can
monitor the performance
of your recommender, as well
as the health of your data
integrations.
So here's what the
dashboard looks like.
You can monitor your overall
recommender performance,
as well as the
performance on metrics
that you care about
system-wide, like total revenue,
recommender engage
revenue, and so forth.
As well as the performance
of individual recommendation
placements.
So for example, the
performance of your home page.
We can dig in on that
and see how it's doing.
Similarly, you can look
at the health of your data
integration.
So you can see how your
integration is doing.
So for example, you can see
whether the total number
of products looks correct.
Whether the right number
of products is in stock.
Sometimes people accidentally
turn out of stock on
and then forget to turn it back
in stock, so we put this here.
You can make sure that your
product catalog is up to date.
And you can also check the
status of your user event
integration.
So we've actually come across
situations where even one
team manages the
recommender and another team
manages the broader
website experience.
And that team will
accidentally delete
the pixel of the team that's
doing the recommender.
So you would see
stuff like that,
where there's a
massive user event
drop here from this dashboard.
And a common problem
we also see is
that people send product
IDs in their user events
that actually are not in
the product catalog itself.
So we help you
track that as well.
Because obviously,
if you send us
a product ID that doesn't
exist in the product catalog,
then we can't do
anything with it.
So you can track
that here as well.
And then also one
of the benefits
of being part of
Google Cloud Platform
is that there are all sorts of
other systems for maintaining
production systems that we
can be natively integrated to.
So for example, you can
check your API metrics here.
People especially care about
the latency and the error rate
of their predict method in terms
of retrieving recommendations.
So you can monitor that here.
I'm going to set it to that
filter to the predict API
method.
And you can see
the total traffic,
the errors that are happening,
the latency of these calls.
So obviously, a lot of you
want to keep the recommender
at the 95th percentile
within 150 milliseconds,
just to make sure it's a
highly dynamic experience.
So you can check that at any
time, as well as more detailed
latency view here.
Next, you can go over individual
errors that you've hit.
So this is also a common issue
where people send poor data.
So we can allow you to deep
dive on what the errors are.
And finally, one
of the big things
in terms of making sure the
recommender is making money
for you day in and
day out, is you
have to actually make sure
it's working on a daily basis.
But you don't want to
look at the dashboard
every single day, right?
So if you want to avoid that,
you can also set up alerting.
So here, for example,
in this demo project,
we've set up an alert for when
the predict errors is above 0.
So if there's ever some
kind of system problem
that causes the
pipeline to break,
then you can be
alerted without you
having to look at the
dashboard every day.
So all sorts of
functionality to ensure
that your recommender is
making money for you day in
and day out.
So on top of having state of the
art models and recommendation
techniques.
If we go back to the slides.
And finally, since these
questions always get asked,
I wanted to let you know
upfront that you can rest easy.
So your data isn't used
for any other Google
customer or Google product.
It just belongs to you and
it sits inside your project.
Your data isn't mixed with
that of other Google customers.
We don't mix all the
user events together
and create one master model.
There's one model
per customer that we
will train on a daily basis.
You always can delete your
data and models at any time.
This is a commonly
asked question.
And finally, we support
GDPR compliance.
And now I would like to
introduce Robert and Dan
from eMAG, one of the largest
online retailers in Eastern
Europe and whom we are
honored to have as one
of our pilot customers.
ROBERT NECULAE: Hello, everyone.
My name is Robert Neculae.
And I am Targeting
Product Owner at eMAG.
And this is Dan Belibov,
one of our best engineers.
We are part of eMAG's
targeting team.
And today we are going to
speak about recommendations
and our experience with the
Google Recommendations AI.
So this is what I have
learned in the past five years
working in the
targeting business.
Nobody wants to be--
sorry just joking-- nobody
wants to shop alone.
We can say that
today the internet
is about personalization.
We have social media
apps, news feeds,
or streaming platforms that
are providing experiences
based on user interest.
And also e-commerce
platforms are
trying to adapt to this trend.
As Tin-Yun has mentioned,
it's not an easy job.
But this is our job.
We need to understand
the customers' needs
and to provide a personalized
shopping experience
for each one of our users.
First of all, a few
things about who are.
eMAG, it's a Romanian unicorn.
The company was founded in
2001 and it was valuated
at over $1 billion in 2018.
We are an organization
which is rapidly
expanding in the
region, aiming to become
the largest online retailer
in this part of Europe.
Today eMAG is the largest
marketplace in Romania.
It is a top online retailer
in Bulgaria and Hungary.
And is also present in Poland.
We have over 4,000
talented people
that work every day to make
our customers' lives better
by saving them time and money.
At eMAG we use
technology and innovation
to facilitate the best
online shopping experience.
So the Google Cloud invitation
to test the new Recommendation
AI was exactly what we need
for our recommendation project.
eMAG's goal is to
deliver the most friendly
and the helpful
shopping experience
by offering a wide range
of products and categories.
Services that are always updated
based on the client's needs.
Our team, the targeting team,
is responsible for developing
the internal
recommendation engine,
managing how our
platforms adapt and react
to each user through
personalized content
in our recommendation widgets
or in any other areas.
Why is this important?
Because more than
20% of our daily
orders are from recommendations.
Now my colleague, Dan, will
present our rec app, Alfred.
DAN BELIBOV: Thanks, Robert.
As Robert already
mentioned, our main aim
is to create a unique
experience for each eMAG user.
In order to do this, we
created a personal assistant
who will know customers'
preferences and habits, too.
His name is Alfred.
Alfred is a max recommendation
app, and he's pretty busy.
All in all, he
should provide over
1 billion unique
recommendations per month.
In order to do this, we're
using internal or third party
recommendation algorithm to
generate recommendations which
will be shown in
widgets in order
to provide it in
customers touchpoint.
Of course, Alfred has some
service responsibilities,
some SLAs.
For example, he knows that he
should recommend more than 99%
of success recommendations and
he has only 250 milliseconds
to provide best commendations
for each customer.
Alfred knows that humans
deliver an average
of 7,000 requests per second
on all four platforms mentioned
above.
In addition to this, he
should provide them separately
for desktop site, mobile site,
mobile app, and targeting
application.
In order to do all
this job, Alfred
needs some resources,
which are represented
by its infrastructure.
He gets 16 web server
machines, 8 worker machines,
20 database machines of
four different types,
and 9 queue machines
of two different types.
We should agree,
it's a great amount
of resources used for
Alfred's day-by-day business.
But it's not all.
Where is the day in
the year when everyone
wants to ship faster
and to get perfectly
fitted products for them?
We're speaking
about Black Friday.
In this day, Alfred knows that
he must roll up his sleeves
and provide more than
20,000 requests per second,
with a maximum error rate of 1%.
In order to ensure this, we
need to scale his resources up
to three times.
As we have mentioned, Alfred has
some friends, some third party
recommendation engines.
And his new best friend
is Recommendations AI.
For us it took only
five working days
to teach Alfred to speak
with his new friend.
In just seven days, we
had the first model live,
continuing to improve it
and testing it in our site.
We have configured
Google Tag Manager
to send user events
to Recommendations AI,
freeing Alfred
from doing his job.
So our app sends
catalog item updates,
ensuring near real-time stock
updates and recommendations.
As a result, in first month,
you can have your first model
live as we had one.
Important to mention here,
we made two integrations, one
with PHP and one with Golang.
It was very simple.
Now Robert will show
us some more numbers.
ROBERT NECULAE: So the first
Recommendation AI scenario
tested was other
items you may like.
On eMAG, the best interaction
with the recommendations
is on their product page
on the first widget.
So we have tested
other items you
may like versus our own
scenario that we have previously
used for this position.
Related items or content
based filtering algorithm.
What about the results?
We had an important increase
in click through rate, 26%.
Rec-driven conversion
rate was boosted with 32%.
And the rec-driven revenue
was boosted with 40%.
Also, we have noticed a
significant 5% increase
in total revenue precision.
Pretty cool, huh?
So this is not all.
We have also tested the
frequently bought together
scenario.
This time the widget
is lower on the page
under stack composition.
And it usually contains
cross-selling product
recommendations based
on manual rules created
by our commercial department.
This time the results
was even better.
We have 100% increase in the
rec-driven click through rate
and 180% rec-driven
conversion rate increase.
Also we have 180%
rec-driven revenue boost.
We have also 1% increase in
total revenue per session.
As you can see, the differences
are very significant.
And we can definitely say
that they perform better
than the manual rules.
So Dan, what's next?
DAN BELIBOV: As a result
of Alfred integration
and Recommendations AI,
we can free more than 25%
of each previously used
infrastructure resources.
Yeah, that one was big.
Average error rate of
Recommendations AI scenarios
is lower than 0.001%
and it's great for us.
Now the integration
of new scenarios
requires only model training.
For Alfred, everything
can be done in its UI.
What comes next for
Alfred and his new friend?
From our point of view, it's
integration of new scenarios.
It's testing the
existing implementations
and adding Recommendations
AI scenarios in home page,
cart check out, targeting
emails, and others,
while looking forward to all
Recommendations AI available
scenarios.
I want to thank Tin-Yun and the
other Recommendations AI team
for this opportunity.
Thank you.
TIN-YUN HO: All right.
Thanks, guys, for
that great story.
And now, being the
PM for this product,
naturally I've looked closely
at the retail tech space.
And I know there's so much
more to delivering an end
to end magical shopping
experience than just
great machine
learning algorithms.
So here at Cloud AI, we know we
can't do everything ourselves,
and we don't want to do
everything ourselves.
So wherever there
are a great GCP
partners that we can work
with, that is definitely
our preferred route.
And with that, I'd like to
introduce Steve from Certona,
which recently joined
forces with Kibo to deliver
an industry leading
unified Cloud Commerce
Platform with
personalization at its core,
and whom we are proud
to have as a partner.
STEVE QUANDT: I'm Steve Quandt.
I'm the Principal
Architect at Certona.
Certona's been doing
personalization
for almost 15 years now.
We have a pretty good product
base, just recently joining
with Kibo.
With that integration,
now we're able to add
full stack solutions
to our capabilities
as a combined company.
We have cart and checkout
capabilities, order Management,
mobile point of commerce, the
product search and discovery,
content management,
product recommendations,
personalized email
and remarketing,
and real time experience
management, the experience
managements across the
multiple platforms,
personalization at all
the different endpoints.
As Tin-Yun was saying
earlier, recommendations
aren't necessarily that easy.
There is a lot more than
just the recommendations.
We've integrated with
the Recommendation AI.
But there's also the
real time tag management.
We provide tests
and optimization.
Do you have reporting?
We have integrated with
the big data analytics
using BigQuery to provide
our customers their data
and able to share
our data with them.
With recommendations,
there's managing the site.
But there's also managing
the customer experience.
When you have a site and they
have their marketing people
responsible for
what they're doing,
it starts with the
machine algorithms.
But having boost and
bury business rules,
being able to present, being
able to integrate your visitor
profile, being able to
integrate your product context.
There's a lot more
than just the AI.
And with the Certona platform
and the Kibo products,
we're able to integrate
these touch points
and provide an end to end
experience for customer sites.
How it all works is starting
with the online data
and offline data,
integrating that together.
We sessionize your data
for reporting and sharing
internally with our customers.
Send that data,
both as Tin-Yun said
earlier, your previous
session batch data, as well as
your current livestream.
Integrating customer
data, catalog data,
into the Google Cloud Platform.
Getting the
recommendations back.
Presenting it to the site.
And back all the way to
the customer touchpoint,
whether that's their website,
email recommendations,
remarketing recommendations,
in store recommendations.
This is an example of
our experience manager.
This is our user interface
into our platform.
When you're integrating
with the Certona platform,
the Google
recommendations are just
another strategy for how
you present products along
with our standard set.
You just select the
Google recommendations.
And one of the things that
Google provides on top of this
is there is a lot of
sometimes marketing
managers want to introduce
their own business rules.
They want to have certain
slots that they want to target.
Stuff that isn't
necessarily bought together.
Or some other strategy that's
on the page where they want
to highlight particular items.
And they're also wanting
to do AB testing.
All of that comes out of the box
with the Certona recommendation
package.
And integrating with the
Google AI is one of the tools
that we see going
forward that is going
to allow us to scale even
better and take advantage
of current technology in
the recommendation modeling.
Another product that we see
has a huge future with us
is the data science
platform, BigQuery.
Able to easily integrate our
data with our customers' data
and allow for a richer
product experience.
And also for visualization and
digging deeper into the product
set that's available.
Working with Google, why Google?
Definitely there was a strategic
alignment with customers.
We share a lot of
their customers.
A lot of our customers are
already in the Google Platform.
They have the state
of the art AI.
It's an easy integration.
We integrate it
with their web API.
And very simple to use.
They have definitely state
of the art infrastructure.
Scalability issues
aren't an issue.
Being able to have global reach.
Our customers are distributed
all over the world.
To get an edge that's close to
where they need that presence
is definitely something
that Google has for us.
And also, working with
great people here at Google.
And back to Tin-Yun.
Thank you.
TIN-YUN HO: Thank you,
Steve, for sharing
that great introduction
to our partnership.
And now in closing, please note
that we are in limited beta
right now.
So because we've had
significant interest,
we currently only have a
limited number of spots.
But if you're interested, please
contact your Google account
manager to get on the waiting
list and we'll try to get
started ramping you
up as soon as we can.